in apartment viewing in the much-hyped
berlin district of nikon we're only
allowed to film the floor
it's a two-room flat on the ground level
850 euros a month all included some of
these interested tenants have been
searching for months it's really really
really really hard there now your salary
must be three times more than the rent
and we know that the lien is one of the
most desperate city with the unemployed
it was also the salary where when you
work they are not so high
what's my impression it's on the ground
floor facing east it doesn't get much
natural light
I find it expensive for what it is but
the demand for living space in Berlin is
enormous it's estimated the city needs
an extra one hundred and seventy
thousand apartments that's forcing
rental prices up those looking for a
flat have few options for many home
hunting is a full-time job
I remember coming to Berlin 10 years ago
finding an apartment was an easy one the
first apartment I rented had two rooms
and it cost only 500 euro now prices
have doubled in this house in the hip
Prenzlauer Berg neighborhood residents
refused to accept the threat of higher
rents through posters and protests they
successfully campaigned against a new
investor trying to buy the building from
Ferguson as a facility we saw a group of
possible investors they were walking
through the house with investment
brochures speaking in different
languages that's when we thought here
goes our house then we quickly organized
ourselves internally we held meetings
and discussions we knew we had to do
something because we didn't want to sit
back and wait in half a year investors
could buy the house and
of ages away the opponent here not
really a relative Kunz
we live here affordably Rosa goes to the
school nearby this is where we have our
community our friends we had to start
thinking about moving our entire lives
somewhere else guns will understand
moose
such worries pulled the house together
artists and freelancers live here they
pay six euros per square meter a month
in some nearby buildings rents are
almost double few here could afford such
prices but now a public housing company
has agreed to buy the building
Brent's will still increase but only by
a fraction it's a happy ending for these
tenants but they want politicians to do
more for the rest of Berlin it's
fundamental that housing isn't too
expensive that people can have a roof
over their heads and that diverse groups
of people can still afford to live in
the city the campaign posters are still
hanging on the walls they're sending a
message to other tenants about why it's
important to join together and fight for
their rights